bonjour bonjour mademoiselle bonjour
messieurs
quelles que puissent être les
divergences ce qui l'emportent et de
loin c'est ce qui nous rapproche est
ainsi je pense que l'on peut résumer le
télégramme que c'est lui le président
entrant pidoux adressé de l'avion qui le
ramenait vers paris au président des
états unis richard knicks quelles que
puissent être les divergences ce qui
l'emporté de loin
c'est ce qui nous rapproche vous voyez
que le président de la république semble
ne pas vouloir tenir contre désormais
promis la paix dans ces présentes
déclarations des quelques incidents qui
n'ont plus marqué son voyage notamment
des incidents à chicago l'an si vous
voulez bien revenons cette nuit avec le
retour de monsieur madame pompidou à
orly
12h06 ce matin l'appareil présidentiel
s'arrêtaient devant le tapis rouge
déroulé sur l'air d'atterrissage
jusqu'au salon d'honneur quelques
instants plus tard souriant monsieur
pompidou à paris c'est au sommet de la
passerelle suivi de madame pompidou
ils étaient accueillis par monsieur
jacques chaban delmas le premier
ministre une gerbe de roses étaient
remises à madame pompidou et ensemble
ils se dirigèrent vers le salon
d'honneur où se trouvaient tous les
membres du gouvernement
monsieur pompidou serra la main tous les
ministres il se tourne ensuite vers les
personnalités de l'ambassade des états
unis qui étaient là également pour
l'accueillir à monsieur robert blake a
chargé d'affaires des états unis le
président de la république de les dire
comme vous voyez tout va tous les
membres du gouvernement faisait ensuite
cercle autour du président pour
recueillir ses impressions
le président pompidou interpellé par les
journalistes faisait la déclaration
nous voilà de retour et je crois que
chacun comprendra que je réserve mes
réflexions et mes impressions pour le
conseil des ministres qui sera
d'ailleurs cet après midi en tout cas je
voudrais simplement que tous les
français tous les 30 et toutes les
françaises sache que je suis et que nous
sommes au moins aussi satisfait de la
façon dont s'est terminé notre voyage
que jah façon il avait commencé et je
crois que ce que nous avons fait là bas
tu auras bien servi l'amitié américaine
et d'une façon générale la cause de la
paix le chef de l'état quitte à
organiser tous les vices
nous en saurons sans doute plus cet
après midi puisque comme le président
pompidou l'a dit aux journalistes à son
arrivée à orly il y as conseil des
ministres exceptionnellement l'après
midi vous le comprendrez facilement à
15h30 donc à l'élise à ce conseil des
ministres on doit aussi parler des
problèmes agricoles et des problèmes du
marché quand même monsieur giscard
d'estaing doit faire le point sur les
dernières réunions de bruce ahli faut
noter et vous le saviez les ministres de
l'agriculture étaient réunis depuis 48
heures à bruxelles ils devaient n'ont
pas réussi à prendre une décision
concernant les prix du sucre des
céréales et des produits laitiers
ils n'ont pas non plus trouvé la
solution idéale pour résorber les
formations d'excédent de ces trois
produits
une chose dont on a beaucoup parlé hier
soir sur information première si vous
avez vu le film
adieu coquelicots et le débat qui a
suivi vous savez que se tient à lyon
depuis hier matin le congrès de la fnsea
la fédération nationale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles vous avez
peut-être assisté hier à l'émission
notre camarade françois henri de virieu
qui a présenté cette émission et qui
souhaitait ce matin assister aux travaux
seconde journée du congrès a été empêché
par un certain nombre d'agriculteurs
d'entrer dans l'enceinte dû palais des
congrès ces agriculteurs lui reproche
comme l'a fait hier soir en direct en
quittant le débat monsieur de baptiste
serris le père lui reproche d'avoir
donnés distille de l'agriculture
française une image caricaturale fausses
et incomplètes
il faut d'ailleurs noter à ce sujet une
déclaration du ministre français
monsieur duhamel qui participait lui
aussi au débat hier et qui est arrivé à
lyon ce matin monsieur duhamel dit si je
n'avais pas prévu de venir à lyon
l'émission de télévision d'hier mort et
inciter annie pas venir quand
l'agriculture française est attaqué pour
ce monsieur duhamel c'est le devoir du
ministre et à devoir d'honnêteté de me
trouver à vos côtés je pense donc que
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir sur
cette affaire et devra de plus amples
explications
une autre situation préoccupante c'est
sur le front du mauvais temps de la
neige du froid du verbe un peu partout
sur les routes d accident assez sérieux
à déplorer c'est ainsi que 49 personnes
ont été blessées à la suite du dérapage
d'un autocar sur la chaussée verglacée
dans les environs
de cambrai les inondations restent
évidemment préoccupante
vous savez les parisiennes remarques
certainement sens que je donne
l'information il neige à nouveau sur
paris depuis ce matin nous allons si
vous voulez bien faire le point sur le
bassin de la seine et de la marne et
d'autre part sur la saône
hier à cinq mètres 48 aujourd'hui cinq
mètres 58 la scène mort mais plus pour
très longtemps
la décrue du fleuve est prévue à partir
du 7 mars mais elle sera lente la fonte
des neiges en est la cause et les gros
flocons tombant sur paris aujourd'hui ne
sont pas fait pour arranger les choses
la scène si elle se stabilise quelque
peu devra néanmoins atteindre 5 mètre
quatre-vingt dans 48 heures
un espoir hier à corbeil où le fleuve a
baissé de 50 centimes
la situation était calme ce matin à
nanterre mais je pense que dans un
instant avec dominique laurie nous
pourrons avoir de plus amples précisions
je voudrais revenir auparavant sur
l'inauguration cet après midi à paris la
mise en service entre le terme le plus
approprié du périphérique est c'est à
dire que désormais pour ceux qui ne sont
pas parisien vous pourrez éviter paris
en arrivant par l'autoroute du nord
contourner paris par l'est de paris par
un boulevard périphérique complet qui
vous amènera jusqu'à l'autoroute du sud
ceux ci à 15h cet après midi mais
derrière on a inauguré un autre tronçon
l'autoroute il s'agit du des premiers
kilomètres de la liaison autoroutière
entre nancy et metz
j'ai l'impression que j'ai quelques
difficultés à obtenir la liaison avec
nos camarades de nancy je vous précise
que ce tronçon de l'autoroute permet
maintenant de quitter nancy très
facilement puisqu'il y à trois
kilomètres qui permettent d'éviter toute
la banlieue de nancy par une autoroute
et que prochainement la liaison sera
entièrement autoroutière entre nancy
metz et même le luxembourg nanterre donc
la situation calme ce matin la faculté
de droit est fermé à 11 heures il y
avait très peu d'étudiants arrivé à la
faculté de lettres tout autour du
domaine universitaire stationnent
toujours des cars de police et de
gendarmes
le syndic indépendant de la police
nationale vient de publier un communiqué
qui protestent contre le mauvais emploi
des forces de l'ordre et qui je cite
subissent passivement et trop longuement
les violences des maoïstes et autres
gauchistes avant d'être autorisée à
intervenir je pense que maintenant sur
place dominique laurie peut faire le
poids
nanterre hier après-midi violents
affrontements pour la deuxième journée
consécutive
pendant plusieurs heures policiers et
étudiants retranché dans les locaux
universitaires third brutalement les
grenades lacrymogènes éclater les
étudiants ont barn à coups de pierres et
débris de mobilier à plusieurs reprises
la police charge
on compte une centaine de blessés de
part et d'autre certains grièvement
atteints
aucune interpellation n'a été effectuée
oui ce matin enterrait calme le campus
ressemble à une poubelle boueuse jonché
de débris de meubles brise et de pavés
de restes de barricades noircie des
vitres brisées et de l'opo saccagés
hier soir des membres du service d'ordre
s'en sont pris aux voitures sur les
parkings et au restaurant universitaire
ce matin monsieur grimaud préfet de
police étaient sur place
aujourd'hui la faculté de droit 8000
étudiants est fermé pour 24 heures celle
de l'être quinze mille étudiants restent
ouvertes
il ya encore peu d'étudiants ce matin en
terre la tension persiste
voilà donc pour l'actualité la plus
brûlante qui ce matin le conseil des
ministres cet après midi je voulais dit
le conseil de l'ess fns ea qui se
poursuit le retour de monsieur pompidou
et puis la situation à nanterre pour
notre actualitté maintenant il y à 25
ans la france les parisiens surtout
découvrait g denise rené vasarely
vasarely cette fois-là faisait sa
première exposition depuis hier vasarely
exposé à nouveau à paris et comme il est
fidèle il a décidé d'exposer toujours
chez denise rené oui et c'est dans une
galerie denise rené agrandi et embelli
que vasari expose ses dernières
peintures et nouveautés ses sculptures
après s'être longtemps consacré au
dessin et aux problèmes du mouvement de
l'espace vasarely sous l'influencé du
cinéma créé la plastique cinétique
l'écran et plan affirme-t-il mais
permettant le mouvement
il est aussi espace vasari s'attache
donc à créer l'illusion du mouvement de
l'espace de la durée
ils brisent aussi les cloisons
traditionnelle entre peinture et
sculpture il récuse d'ailleurs en ce qui
le concerne ce terme de sculptures et
lui préfère celui d'oeuvre multi
dimensionnelle
toute ma peinture toute ma recherche
cela est basé sur les deux dimensions
c'est dans la mesure où la nécessité se
présente et d'ajouter de nouvelles
dimensions sont les jours de classiques
du plan cela que j'ai découpé au fond
des compositions je les portais dans
l'espace observant ainsi une troisième
une quatrième dimension même le
mouvement pas plus l'espace ce qui a
valu que ces objets
énigmatique mystérieuse pas que vous
voyez pour composer son univers
géométriques vasarely se sert de ce
qu'il appelle l'unité formes couleurs
ces unités placées en perspective
contradictoires lui permettent les
passionnantes recherche optique du
mouvement et du relief auxquelles il
nous a habitués depuis bientôt 25 ans
c'est jean-pierre enquiries qui vous a
fait découvrir cette exposition vasarely
à paris chez denise rené vous vous
souvenez certainement de west side story
n'est peut-être pas vu la comédie
musicale mais vous avez sans doute vu le
film ou en tout cas trini lopez a
popularisé les airs les plus célèbres de
cette comédie musicale qui a duré qui a
triomphé de longues années à new york
son compositeur c'était leonard
bernstein
or bernstein est par ailleurs l'un des
plus célèbre chef d'orchestre grands
pianistes aussi pendant quatre jours et
c'est un événement il va diriger
l'orchestré de paris au théâtre des
champs elysées dès ce soir il va
commencer avec la troisième symphonie de
mahler claude samuel et denise bauer ont
cherché à vous faire découvrir ce
personnage éclectique que leonard
bernstein si éclectique on l'a appelée
l'oiseau rare
une entraide et des saunas nogueira
snake eyes toi
ces enfants c'est le public de bernstein
à new york tel que nous le présente ce
document amérique car bernstein qui est
en ce moment à paris pour diriger
malheur avec l' orchestre de paris est
un homme très occupé il a mille et une
activités les compositeurs auteur de
comédies musicales comme moi ça history
les chefs d'orchestre et il est aussi
pédagogue
moi j'adore enseigner la musique parce
que il y a dans moi même peut-être
éléments de professeurs quelque chose
pédagogique didactique né j'ai fait le
job
comment dit-on sade de partager a
nécessité le la nécessité de partager
avec tout le monde
ce que je le sol ce que je sais de la
musique
et voilà bernstein en action
il ya deux méthodes d' expliquer et
expliquer la musique
ils sont tous les deux très mauvais un
méthodes et les petites histoires
enfantin dont on fait des comparaisons
entre la musique et les rivières et les
montagnes les oiseaux des choses comme
ça
notre méthode est il contraire notre
extrême qui est de fournir un road maps
une carte géographique d'une partition
et moi je cherche un abîme entre les
deux toutes les méthodes sont bonnes et
toutes les comparaisons sont excellentes
pour essayer de faire comprendre la
musique aux enfants et leonard bernstein
n'hésite pas à utiliser un mètre à ruban
etc
m
il n'y aura jamais trop de musiciens
peut-être trop de musiciens
professionnels métro de musiciens
amateurs amateurs de la musique qui font
la musique chez soi la maison mais ce
professeur de musique au maître à ruban
est pratiquement devenu le compositeur
officiel des états unis
puisqu'on vient de lui commander une
symphonie à l'occasion du 200e
anniversaire de l'indépendance des états
unis
leonard bernstein 51 ans au théâtre des
champs-elysées à partir de ce soir parce
que là on change tout à fait de
jean-michel le lieu on va parler de
sport sportive puisse aimer la musique
d'ailleurs chanté la du monde de
patinage du talent ils osent il mettra
ruban sur de la musique
championnats du monde de patinage à
ljubljana et 7 n'est pas là le champion
d'europe qui est en tête actuellement
les figures imposées se termine cet
après midi vers 14 heures devant team ou
l'américain tenant du titre par couple
c'est évidemment le célèbre couple
soviétique rodina olanoff qui est en
tête et qui est bien parti pour être
encore une fois champion du monde
champion de france de ski via 200
concurrentes qui attendent depuis ce
matin de pouvoir prendre le départ du
slalom géant à briançon malheureusement
il y avait trop de vent
et cette première compétition de
championnat a été annulée et reportée à
demain
en cyclisme c'est aujourd'hui le début
du tour d'indre-et-loire encore une
bonne préparation un bon rodage avant
paris-nice qui débutera vous le savez
dimanche
en tout cas il y a dans ce tour d'havré
loire organisé par notre ami des vaches
qui est un coureur de l'île poulidor
letort note à votre profit bien d'autres
champions en boxe vous allez voir
maintenant ismail laguna qui est à
gauche recevoir un droit de ramos était
hier championnat du monde des légers et
laguna a battu le tenant du titre
ramos il est donc de nouveau après une
interruption de quatre ans champion du
monde des poids légers puis d'autres
photographies d'une rencontre qui
passionnait aussi les amateurs du noble
art en france puisqu'il n'ya pas douanes
ou à gauche et qui affrontait hier soir
à montréal le canadien dur elle n'est
pas doisneau a battu durel aux points en
douze reprises paduano qui est à gauche
vous le rappelle sera le prochain
adversaire demain salle certains comme
anne méaux madison square garden de new
york en sport automobile c'est
l'américain mario andretti sur marche
la nouvelle formule a un peu mystérieuse
qui a réalisé le meilleur temps aux
essais de calvi en afrique du sud
on apprend aussi aujourd'hui la mort
accidentelle d'un ancien grand champion
de ski disciplines nordiques il s'agit
de rené mandrillon âgé de 42 ans qui est
tombé du haut de son hôtel en déblayant
la neige l'une de ses filles muriel fait
d'ailleurs partie de l'équipe de france
des espoirs de ski disciplines alpines
en football aujourd'hui grande journée
quarts de finale de la coupe d'europe
des clubs champions quatre rencontres
standard de liège contre lips leeds qui
est un club anglais
le celtic est des causes rencontre de la
fiorentina l'italie vaart l'allemagne de
l'est sont opposés à payer nord de
hollande et enfin galatasaray de turquie
se reposait à legia de varsovie
les jeunes varsovie c'est un club que
saint-etienne connaît bien vous savez
pourquoi les matches retour auront lieu
le 18 mars
enfin handball demi finale on connaît
maintenant les qualifiés à lyon ce sera
roumanie contre danemark hier s'est payé
le luxe d'éliminer la tchécoslovaquie
tenant du titre et à bordeaux
l'allemagne de l'est à la yougoslavie
mais hier soir aussi à ivry des français
jouer au handball ampoules de
consolation il est vrai l'équipe de
france en blanc sur votre écran était
opposé donc aux soviétiques la france
qui a accédé à cette poule d battue en
prenant le meilleur sur les suisses et
dimanche dernier n'a pas retrouver le
tonus qu'il y avait permis au cours du
week-end de donner une réplique
honorable aux allemands dominent et déjà
à la mi temps 13 à 17 les tricolores ne
parvenaient pas et ces images n'explique
via à tromper la défense soviétique
valoir les français tourné devant la
défense critique sans pouvoir la
pénétrer seul michel richard auteur de
cinq buts dont deux sur penalty est
parvenu lui à percer en de trop rares
occasions
bref une équipe de france méconnaissable
qui fit illusion au cours des premières
rencontres et son bras hier soir dans le
médiocre est ce la fatigue est ce le
manque de résistance physique mais
surtout le manque de préparation
ou alors le moral trop bas on ne sait
trop en tout cas la victoire de l'union
soviétique par 25 à 14 points d'écart
correspond à la physionomie de cette
rencontre l'équipe de france doit se
reprendre ce soir face aux japonais
toujours en poule de consolation enfin
n'oublions pas que l'élimination des
soviétiques des quarts de finale
championnats du monde a été élu nero
surprise des championnats ils sont une
valeur nettement supérieur aux français
quant aux français je vous le disais il
ya un instant il manque de préparation
athlétique chacune alexandre c'est le
grand boum pour les arts ménagers des
désirs matin oui c'était hier matin
l'ouverture des arts ménagers nous
sommes allés filmer les toutes dernières
nouveautés proposées par ce 39e salon
nous avons sélectionné les nouveautés
les plus appropriées aux besoins de la
femme moderne
vous allez voir tout d'abord une
poussette à provisions conçu pour monter
descendre des escaliers suivant le
besoin
on a remarqué cette année beaucoup de
couleurs ne serait ce que pour les
casseroles qui ont en plus une forme
assez fonctionnel l'émail extérieur et
intérieur est très solide il avons fait
l'expérience avec du lait on passe une
éponge à l'intérieur de la iv hall alors
que l'ailé aboudi ce qui généralement sa
lippe énormément et osa versac la
casserole et entière mon propre donc
plus de problème pour la vaisselle
le balais serpillères faisant un
avantage énorme serein sans jamais y
mettre les mains dans un système
mécanique très hostile à température de
chaque mauvaise nouvelle le degré désiré
mais admettons 38 degrés vous ouvrez
votre mitigeur est automatiquement vous
avez instantanément les 38 degrés
ensuite faut passer du temps à la douche
avec les deux doigts de la main vous
tirez sur le clapet est automatiquement
vous êtes alimenter en bons
vous avez un système réglable sur
fringues
pour votre salle de bain des meubles
inaltérable et peu encombrant à un ou
plusieurs tiroirs de couleurs à moins
que vous ne préfériez ce bac à l'âge les
68 installateur de cuisines débordent
d'imagination cette année il allie
l'esthétique et la fantaisie au
rationnel éléments de rangement en bois
blancs accessoires clair ce même bois en
rouge avec évier les plaques de cuisson
inoxydable ultramoderne cette cuisine
bicolore beaucoup de carrelage
coordonner avec les rangements
à moins que vous ne choisissiez un
papier plastifié qui résiste aux taches
de graisse se lave comme une peinture il
est auto collants et se pose en quelques
heures
quoi de plus discret que ses accessoires
incorporer plus de recoins tout est
encastré
une nouveauté qui nous vient des états
unis un papier isolant plus dur en bon
sec et décolorée si vous prenez la
précaution de l'envelopper dans ce
papier isolant il peut rester des
semaines au réfrigérateur
cet appareil est un responsable qui
marche sur cartouche très facile à
manier pour attirer simplement un capot
vous remets vous appuyez et pour
l'allumage paquet simplement les
allumettes et vous avez un riche notable
enfin la vedette de ce salon le four
autonettoyant un poulet vienne cuir le
four est propre
car les graisses ont été automatiquement
détruites pendant la cuisson
voici donc ce que le 39e salon des arts
ménagers vous propose cette année au
palais des expositions à la défense je
vous rappelle qu'il sera ouvert jusqu'au
dimanche 15 mars compris bien nous
allons passer maintenant à un tout autre
sujet puisque nous allons suivre un
train stop c'est à dire que les gens qui
veulent monter dans le tram sont un
signal fort a thing et le train s'arrête
il ya commode
on arrive peut-être pas toujours à
l'heure mais enfin quand on n'a pas de
voiture c'est bien pratique comme il
était une fois dans l'aveyron de petites
lignes de chemin de fer qui avait un
gros déficit alors dans les bureaux des
chemins de fer à paris un responsable se
mit à réfléchir consulta des dossiers
c'est un rapport en 15 exemplaires et
décide à la fin des gardes barrières
c'est ainsi que les barrières de vin
automatique seulement voilà les gardes
barrières dans l'aveyron sont parfois
chef de gare surtout sur une petite
ligne agro difficile
alors depuis le début du mois l'autorail
rodez toulouse s'arrête au gré et à la
fantaisie du clip
c'est une plaie pour l'heure tous ses
marchés
morrison et à la nécessité faisant loi
les aveyronnais ont appris à lever le
pouce au bord de la voie ferrée et
contrairement à ce qui se produit très
souvent le long des routes nationales
chaque fois qu'il lève le pouce un
chauffeur s'arrête
voilà donc comment loin de là à paris un
monsieur dans un bureau a pu faire le
bonheur de ses concitoyens en inventant
l'autorail stop
me
tu pourrais être en mesure d'arrêter ce
cas les voyageurs
il ya me voyagent et aux passes et
siliana décemment et l'essai du chemin
qui nous avait dit avant le départ de
klaxons
et oui la vie voyez vous c'est souvent
beaucoup moins compliqué qu'on ne le
croit et dans l'aveyron on en est
persuadé
nous allons sans tarder passer la parole
à michel tardieu qui est à la bourse de
paris
je suis ravi de suivre votre train
jacqueline et d'autant que les nouvelles
de la bourse aujourd'hui sont nettement
meilleures il y a une résistance
générale de la cote et de nombreuses
valeurs sont fermes
pourtant et notamment d'ailleurs à la
construction électrique la construction
électrique se distingue ainsi que les
banques
pourtant le plan stabilisation fait
sentir ses effets depuis le début de
l'année les immatriculations de voitures
neuves ont diminué et notre part
l'immobilier ne va pas très bien non
plus les promoteurs se plaignent de
manquer d'argent et les acheteurs
éventuels d'appartements se plaignent de
manquer de crédit pour acquiescer
appartement qui il faut bien le dire
n'ont pas baissé notre part sur le
marché de l'emploi pour la première fois
depuis plusieurs mois on constate au
début de février une légère augmentation
des demandes d'emploi non satisfaites
en bonne logique ces informations
traduites sur le plan boursier aurait dû
inciter les opérateurs à une certaine
retenue parce que bien sûr quand
activité économique ralentie
la bourse perd un petit peu le moral et
bien en fait n'en est rien
peut-être parce que tout le monde sait
bien qu'un plan stabilisation c'est fait
pour ralentir et que quand on freine
c'est précisément parce qu'on espère
arriver à ralentir et paradoxalement un
certain nombre d'observateurs voient à
sa table autistes un motif d'optimisme
dans le début de pessimisme de quelques
secteurs industriels ils disent plus
vite les objectifs du plan stabilisation
seront atteints plus vite le
gouvernement pourra relancer l'expansion
d'ailleurs les résultats du plan ne sont
pas tous négatifs puisque en février les
réserves d'or et deux vices de la france
se sont accrues de 399,3 millions de
francs ce qui les porte à 21,7 milliards
de francs en tout cas les entreprises ne
se laisse pas aller à la main
auzits et si l'on en juge par les appels
qu'ils lancent actuellement sur le
marché financier
elles ont l'air décidé à investir pour
être prêtes à tirer parti du redémarrage
de l'économie qui ne manquera pas ce
produit
vous savez les emprunts et les
augmentations de capital se succèdent à
un rythme rapide
la prochaine annonce et est celle de
peau claire qui va distribuer une
gratuite pour quatre en même temps et
met une nouvelle action à souscrire en
numéraire pour 4 également on parle
aussi sur le marché de l'augmentation de
capital probable la société française
des pétroles bp qui se ferait à raison
d'une action vendu 60 francs pour deux
anciennes la multiplication des
émissions risquent évidemment de rang
des boursiers de plus en plus exigeants
il faudra leur proposer de belles
perspectives de gains c'est d'ailleurs
la seule façon d'élargir le nombre des
épargnants qui investissent en bourse
pour l'instant d'après une enquête de
l'ifop
l'institut français d'opinion publique
réalisée pour les services économiques
de publicis 6% seulement les ménages
français possèdent des actions ci
correspond à environ un million de
familles auxquelles bien sûr il faudrait
ajouter tous les porteurs d'obligations
pour connaître le nom des gens qui
s'intéressent à la bhl pour augmenter
cette clientèle boursière il faudrait
que la cote de la bourse de paris offre
un plus grand nombre de sociétés
multinationales en effet l'évolution
actuelle du marché montrent que les
épargnants préfèrent les grandes
sociétés celles qui ont une implantation
solide sur les marchés internationaux
mais pour grandir bien sûr les sociétés
ont besoin d'argent mais c'est une sorte
de cercle vicieux dont les finances et
doivent réussir à sortir
bien sûr le moyen le plus souvent
utilisés par les sociétés françaises
pour grandir c'est la concentration soit
qu'il s'agisse de fusion entre des
sociétés déjà parente c'est le cas de
l'opération que p chine est en train de
réaliser aux états unis où la société
regroupe ses filiales soit qu'il s'agit
simplement de rapprochement entre
sociétés indépendantes
c'est le cas aujourd'hui des ressorts du
nord de la manufacture général des
ressorts et dac mer qui constitue un
groupement d'intérêt économique sous le
nom de ressorts industrie assez
curieusement fortune le grand magazine
économique américain écrit aujourd'hui
que la manie des fusions risque
dangereuse pour les économies
européennes fortune résume sa pensée en
disant que ce sont les petits
ont survécu dans l'histoire et après
histoire alors que les dinosaures ont
disparu
on peut se demander si l'analyse du
journal américain est tout à fait
désintéressée et c'est en définitive ce
ne sont pas sur tous les monopoles
nationaux qui risquent de se créer en
europe qui gêne les américains d'autant
que ces monopoles sont bien sûr aidé par
les gouvernements européens fortune en
effet s'en prend surtout aux géants
européens qui n'ont pas des marchés
intérieurs à leur taille
ce raisonnement est difficilement
acceptable parce que il reviendrait à
dire que seuls les américains qui ont un
très grand marché intérieur pourrait
avoir des sociétés de première dimension
qui elle se taillerait se partageraient
tous les grands marchés du monde sur le
marché de l'or ou les américains bien
qu'il n'ait pas une demande intérieure
importante ont remporté vous le savez
des succès très important
et bien aujourd'hui la barre elle la
gauche sont en léger repli tandis que
les pièces sont irrégulières orantes je
crois que le pin est père au dernier
cours 20 centimes par rapport à son
cours de la veille
le pin et va apparaître le voilà il est
à 152 90 oui c'est valentine de moi qui
y ai ici
la bourse de paris avoue jacqueline
alexandre je crois philippe gildas
qu'ils aient une information de droit de
l'information mais je chaban delmas a
reçu ce matin pendant une heure quinze
monsieur guichard et monsieur marcellin
à propos de nanterre d'autre part orly
trafic fermé depuis une heure en raison
de la neige qui continue de tomber sur
paris qui paralyse les pistes bien
mesdames et messieurs je crois que midi
télé midi est maintenant terminée au
revoir à demain